on est avec didier haug allemand ce soir
bénévole depuis 20 ans dans une salle de
sport qu'il a créé à sevran vous est
hébergé chez une amie qui vient de
décéder vous toucher le rsa tient non
330 euros par mois ne riez pas le
demander avant vous ne mangez qu'une
fois par jour actuellement
depuis quand votre situation s'est
dégradée de la sorte
bon déjà bonjour merci là c'est nous qui
vont en version 10 10 je suis assez
surpris d'ailleurs d'être là aujourd'hui
je suis très heureuse il agit pas du
style à faire des demandes jusqu'à
maintenant je donc oui j'ai créé une
association
à côté de ça je suis aussi bénévole dans
une association avec des policiers pour
leur rapprochement police et population
donc je fais des cours d'initiation aux
ebooks autre chose bénévolement oui mais
bon vous vous gagnez votre vie a comme
en avant bah ça a été compliqué j'ai
fait beaucoup d'intérim j'ai fait plein
de métiers d'accor j'ai fait les saisons
d'hiver j'ai fait photographes sont les
pistes jacquot et plongeurs pour vous
vous démerdez quoi va dire voilà tout à
fait voilà vous arrivez toujours à voile
a trouvé un petit truc enchaîner des
petits boulots je suis pas la rue déjà
c'est bien je l'aï toujours qu'il ya
pire que moi mais bon je commence à en
avoir marre de me dire qu'il ya pire que
moi j'aimerais bien
non mais là ça fait des années que je
cherche à faire une formation
je me suis inscrit un peu pour faire une
formation ont envoyé des offres d'emploi
j'ai eu beau répéter donc un moment
donné j'ai baissé les bras
vous voulez faire une formation brevet
d'éducateur sportif ça fait des années
j'ai plus de 30 ans d'expérience dans
une fédé qui n'est pas reconnu d'état
mais qui est quand même déclaré en
préfecture
donc j'ai un club depuis plus de vingt
ans je participe au téléthon je
participais y trouver votre formation
qu'est ce qu'ils vont à l'endroit où
faire la formation c'est l'argent offert
l'information c'est tout
là en ce moment j'ai des envies des gens
qui sont en train de me donner un petit
coup de main des gens font partie de la
police pour essayer de l'aiguillé mais
depuis le confinement c'est en stand by
mais parce que tout le monde a refermé
on peut pas
en fait avant le côté je ne peux pas
travailler aussi pour gagner de l'argent
pour me payer ma voix mais en fait en
fait vous avez été victimes aussi de
l'aco vite puisque avant vous devez
faire une formation d'éducateur sportif
oui et donc la comida tout anéanti donc
là aujourd'hui j'ai vu noël là pour
ensemble pour vous dire je me suis même
cassé le pied un petit peu avant le
confinement j'ai même pas fini ma
rééducation parce que le confinement et
on m'a jamais rappelé donc j'ai fait
tout ça dans l'éducation
je me porte bien ça se passe bien alors
heureusement qu'ils avaient que j'étais
bénévole dans une association
parce que je garde ça aussi pour garder
un lien social et en même temps vous
rendez service à tout le monde c'est à
dire vous êtes sur une mission parce que
c'est quand même important de le
souligner hier que vous ça fait 20 ans
que vous êtes bénévole et que vous
essayez de rapprocher les populations la
police ou ce genre de choses qui sont
des vraies missions de génération dans
une ville dite à difficulté a souvent
oui ça là et je m'occupe d'enfants
d'adultes et ça passe très très très
bien aujourd'hui didier vous avez dit à
nos équipes vous ne mangez qu'une seule
fois par jour
oui essayez vous pouvez pas voilà pas
quand je pourrai manger deux fois je
mange deux fois par jour mais bon
aujourd'hui en février devrait la fois
par jour et je dors sous un toit
bon le dans mon malheur ce qui vient de
se passer j'ai été hébergée par une
personne qui vient de décéder en fait
une personne âgée qui avait ses caisses
et col du fémur qui rentre à l'hôpital
et qui est décédé du coheed voilà ça
fait deux mois qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital
voilà donc le clama situation oui et un
petit peu compliqué après bon je suis un
bâton ce qui a pour l'instant ben je
m'occupais beaucoup avec l'association
qui s'appelle raid aventure organisation
comment vous faites aujourd'hui didier
pour vivre au jour le jour c'est ça et
quand on fait de l'argent
quel argent vous n est ce que
aujourd'hui je le verrai ça 330 euros
mois par mois et comme j'ai une certaine
fierté je ne fais pas je ne vais pas aux
restos du coeur je ne veux rien aucune
honte à l'eau restos du coeur je sais
mais vraiment il ya plein de gens qui y
vont et c'est pas une honte
il ya plus en plus de gens qui sont
obligés d'aller au resto du coeur pour
deux trois mois
c'est pour vous et c'est je rende
innocent c'est pas une honte surtout
aujourd'hui vraiment d'aller au resto du
coeur au contraire on l'est on les
remercie heureusement que les restos du
coeur sont là et ils secours populaire
aussi c'est vraiment un bail non parce
que je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
aussi beaucoup de téléspectateurs qui
peut-être ne regarde aussi qu'ils ont
honte d'aller au resto du coeur et qui
disent non je peux pas aller aux restos
du coeur je peux pas aller au secours
populaire
je vous dis il n'y a aucune honte
aujourd'hui et ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui vraiment du jour au
lendemain
donc vraiment ai aucune envie je suis
très conscient je vais mais bon je
préférais être capable de m'en sortir
par moi même plutôt que de me faire
aider maintenant je suis très content
qu'ils aient des z comme ça pour les
gens que les vous savez c'est peut-être
parfois un coup de pouce pour deux trois
quatre mois et puis peut-être après pour
repartir
voilà parce que là il y à des mois
difficiles qui vont arriver et peut-être
qu'il faut essayer de trouver toutes les
aides possibles pour dont ces mois là
est peut-être après essayé de repartir
mais bon votre carte c'est la parfaite
illustration
c'est ce que vous disiez ne manière plus
théorique et là on a un cas pratique
c'est on n'a que l'inde est
théoriquement vous devriez pas avoir
aussi peu intéressant et ça c'est plus
élevé théoriquement votre sujet le
logement parce que j'entends que
vous avez une interrogation alors vous
avez vous allez vous loger la dernière
puisque cet homme est décédé
vous dormez ou actuellement pour
l'instant je suis toujours au même
endroit parce qu'il ya une histoire
d'héritage toutes les maisons de quoi la
maison va être vendu d'accord je ne sais
pas combien de temps j'ai encore notre
job c'est de faire en sorte que les gens
qui n'ont pas de toit en trouve un
second a mis le paquet on a de l'argent
on a des endroits d'urgence alors ce
n'est pas fantastique mais enfin on a un
toit on peut dormir on a un lit et en
termes d'argent
compte tenu de ce que vous faites compte
tenu de ce que vous faites pour la
collectivité
on doit pouvoir vous aider c'est là où
on a un problème dans l'intervention
détail et merci sert il de faire ces
tribunes 7
cette émission parce qu'au fond c'est là
c'est le moment de dire les aides elles
existent les aides elles sont pour vous
les aides on les a pas créé pour des
personnes qui sont pas chères on a créé
le saint pour tous les français je le
dis aussi pour vous madame
on les a créées pour tous les français
pour les petits comme vous dites et pour
faire en sorte que ils se sortent de
cette mise et qu' ils passent le cap
et après on sait que vous allez vous
accrocher on sait que vous dites que
vous travaillez vous dites que vous avez
envie de travailler on sait que vous
allez vous accrocher mais il faut qu'on
vous viennent en aide moi j'ai un peu
envie de dire voilà il faut qu'on en
discute c'est pas possible c'est à nous
d'aller venir vers vous pour vous qu
avait un peu d'argent etc
et c'est un mois deux mois trois mois
enfin moi je fais l'hypothèse qu'on n'a
pas cédé à nantes dans un conte création
de madame la ministre
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on parler d'un
problème de communication
aussi vous pouvez pas traiter tous les
cas vous n'avez pas traiter au cas par
cas donc est ce qu'il faudrait pas
mettre en place une plateforme un site
où vraiment chaque personne puisse aller
expliquer ces problèmes et qu'il ait des
réponses à ces problématiques puisqu'on
voit qu'il ya plein dead on les connaît
pas bien c'est un peu flou pour que les
personnes sachent plus où aller ce qui
se tient peut-être pendant 2 3 mois je
vais peut-être avoir cette aide là qui
va me permettre de rebondir après et
c'est vrai qu'on le voit autant avec
valérie qui avait décidé aujourd'hui ils
sont dans l'inconnu ils disent vermont
va se tourner le gouvernement ils
entendent et dz
ils me disent on n'en bénéficient pas
donc est-ce qu'il ya pas moyen de créer
quand même quelque chose ou ccc logiciel
acquis assez faciles à créer ou chaque
français pouvaient voilà pour être
donnés seconde édition
oui non moi ce que je veux dire c'est
moi lettre que j'ai besoin c'est être
capable de me sentir tout seul c'est pas
d'être assisté tout le temps c'est
justement avoir un diplôme qui me permet
par exemple d auto entrepreneur de 8 à
vie puisque vous devez faire une
formation d'éducateur si pendant ces
mois difficiles où on traverse cette
crise sanitaire
incroyable vous pouvez avoir des aides
oui après on espère que vous allez
pouvoir faire votre formation
d'éducateurs et que vous allez pouvoir
repartir
c'est vraiment un coup de pouce de deux
trois mois qui vous permettra peut-être
pas retranchements contenait des
activités de bénévolat que vous avez
fait c'est quand même un juste retour de
la société vers vous bien sûr oui même
le dire comme ça mais bon c'est pas mon
butin m mais à un moment il faut aussi
se dire que j'ai 35 ans et il faut à un
moment donné que je me sente tout seul
aussi dans un an vous en sortirez dans
un non on ne sera pas au même enfin on
sera pas dans la même situation
ouais didier j'ai l'impression que c'est
une question de fierté
oui mais mais il faut pas il faut pas
penser à ça parce que auto et regardez
où comme comme la dynamique vous avez
fait beaucoup beaucoup de bénévolat
pendant toute votre vie aujourd'hui vous
avez besoin d'un petit coup de pouce
pour trois à quatre mois
et puis ensuite vous allez faire votre
formation d'éducateurs et je suis sûr
que ça va aller beaucoup mieux pour vous
et j'espère vous allez pouvoir vous en
sortir mais faut pas que vous ayez honte
faut pas que vous soyez dans dans un rue
ou à la wii pour ma fierté j'ai pas
envie d'aller au resto du coeur j'ai pas
envie de ménage était laide ou telle
aide
oui s'il faut vous dire faut dire que
c'est provisoire et que ça va peut-être
vous permettre de repartir après faut
vous dire que vous vivez dans un beau
pays dans lequel on a mis en place et
les restos du coeur vous savez on les
accompagnons les finances et c'est
justement pour ce type de situation
et derrière à la question que vous posez
qui aimait au fond où est ce qu'on
trouve les questions réponses etc
alors vous allez me dire s'est
éparpillée mais il ya le site du
ministère de l'économie où il ya
beaucoup de documents notamment pour les
artisans pour les commerçants pour les
auto entrepreneurs un pas seulement pour
ce cours un grand magasin mais aussi
pour ceux qui sont en auto alors energy
on est allé voir avec les équipes
s'était passé et bac + 5
c'est vraiment c'est incompréhensible je
vous dis les veaux l'ajout d'un message
et c'est vrai que on aimerait avoir un
truc simple didier il dit il rentre tout
c'est des données geci j'ai ça
j'aimerais avoir cela comment faire vers
quoi on se dirige et la voient là parce
que là c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je vous
dis moi qui est quelqu'un qui suit pas
une lumière
j'ai rien compris